millions of students all across the
country have safely returned to the
classroom but that is still not the case
for most of clark county
later today district leaders will
discuss a partial return to class for
ccsd
hector mejia is live at district
headquarters with a preview hi hector
hey there alex good morning and ccsd
here is set to go over transitioning to
a hybrid plan but right now it's just a
discussion
and a vote is not scheduled until
november 12th and many parents teachers
and students are hoping to get a better
idea of what to expect
after today's virtual meeting trustees
will go over updates from the southern
nevada health district about coronavirus
and schools
a report from the agenda shows there's
still a higher risk of transmission in
schools based on information
as of monday trustee linda cavazos
believes a potential spike
in cases may hurt the district more if a
hybrid plan is approved
she says the board is carefully weighing
its options when it comes to that
decision
my concerns would be are we going to
make it worse
by reopening too soon and then having to
disrupt
everyone's schedules that they're just
kind of now
they worked very hard to get into i
guess i think you would say you know
kind of like a groove
here trustee cavazos adds
the meeting should also focus on the
resources for reopening
for example she said does the district
have enough teachers willing to return
back to the classroom and again today's
meeting is only a discussion it's set to
start at
five in the evening reporting live
outside ccsd headquarters hector mejia
8 news now